hello folks welcome to rational science
the only site on the internet that does
physics
everybody else does what they do
mathematics what is mathematics it's
when you move concepts around
here we can only move or propose only to
move
objects
you also do a little bit of extension
extinction of man
and
any subject related to that okay
we say that we are the last humans or
last generation of humans on earth we
don't have very long to go
okay so let's get on with some of these
issues uh related to extinction some
people sent some
questions and so i'm gonna address those
okay uh and lately we've been talking
about um
the subject started a couple weeks ago
where i mentioned that
[Music]
there's a case where this fellow
he changed his sex
he didn't change categories in
kickboxing he changed sex and so now
after
30 35 years
uh of being a male he turned himself
into a woman
and now he's fighting women and he's
beating them
making money
becoming famous and the women are a
little upset saying look this guy is
really a guy
and he looks like a guy i mean he's got
the body of a of a man
but suppose he's a woman because uh he
made a sex change operation and so the
question is uh
should that be allowed
and then the
counter argument is why not
i mean you know we have women they want
equality
uh in many fields and
uh
they probably deserve you know in every
field uh be equal to you to men
the question is why not in sports
why not uh make all sports unisex
even the tough ones like you know boxing
and uh wrestling and so on weightlifting
bodybuilding all these
rough
activities we can call them right why
not why not have everybody compete
against everybody in fact
women will come up the ranks much faster
become better because they have to
compete against men
there's going to be a learning curve and
the question is if that learning
curve leads to equality where someday
you get a boxing champion which is a
woman instead of a man beats the
heavyweight champion of the world uh
male
and we have a female world champion why
not isn't is that possible
and uh i'm sure there's a lot of
opinions out there especially men
uh but the the question is you know
women have come up the ranks there are
women who fight out there and they are
professionals
uh these guys look at themselves he's
just a girl she's just a girl
no you're not
you're not looking at a girl you're
looking at a gladiator she can beat the
tar out of you you know so
why not why not have unisex sports that
way we have told equality everywhere in
uh salaries and rights
sports right
and so some people answered or made
questions around that uh subject here's
one felon
and he says most relationships women
have more power than men okay
a typical woman controls the
relationships thanks to three major
levels of powers
positions uh herself as the most
valuable
party sets a frame where the man's job
is to cater to her needs assess the
man's value and worthiness based on how
well he provides for her most women do
it subconsciously and most men accept
her frames without even realizing they
are being controlled
says women treat men like children women
get quiet when they're flatter men women
compare men to other men
the majority of women aren't interested
in physical competition with men
yeah they're not uh interested of course
not and likewise most men are not even
in competition uh in sports
you know uh it's for people who
who want to make money who might want to
make a career out of it that i'm talking
about obviously it's a small percentage
of humanity and i'm saying if if those
women want to make money
well what's wrong with having them
compete against men
and if we do it today you know more men
will beat
more women you know the men will be in
the upper half
of those rankings but the issue is uh
how much time will it take for
women to females to catch up and be on
the par with men
isn't that possible
and so that's the question you know you
should ponder right i'm not saying they
will i'm just saying that they might and
it's just a question of how much time
we have if we have very little time as i
think we have on the clock that
extinctions around the corner i don't
think it'll ever happen but if we had
another 100 years 200 years
everybody competing against everybody
why not
and as far as you know being dominated
and so on you know you got all kinds of
relations out there you know you got men
who dominate women women who dominate
men you you've got uh
women who treat men like kids and vice
versa you know so i think you've got
everything out there it's just a
question of uh you know i don't know
what percentages are on either side but
to say that women control men yeah to
some degree and men control women as
well so
i don't know
uh
i don't know if you can reach any
conclusion on that i'm not even sure
there's a study
that shows something like that okay
okay another fellow along the same lines
same issue says chromosomes alone not
only denominators for sex uh he's saying
that you know we should not judge
um whether a person's male or female
just on the chromosomes like women you
know double x and you have males x y
uh
he gives the example here there is a uh
in intersex birth defect um
born individuals that are more common
nowadays they have kleinfelder syndrome
also called xxy syndrome i guess they
are born with all these chromosomes
these weird chromosomes there are also
other types of chromosome disorders the
definition for sex has to be more
rigorous than just the chromosomes
uh yeah i'm not sure you can find a
perfect definition not for sex
uh all i'm saying is we have a practical
definition something that is more or
less objective and that applies to
over 99 of humanity now as time goes by
we have some weird cases uh probably
because we've had a lot of inbreeding
for
thousands of years you know we've bred
only with our species and after a while
you know you whittle all that
diversity away
over time you know
you know there's a
more uniformity in our
jeans in our teen pool and there you
have an animal it's the uh komodo dragon
and he doesn't
she really i'm going to talk about the
cheese
has a wz
chromosome and she is able to have
children all by herself without the aid
of a
male
okay and other lizards and other animals
have that ability as well
and so yeah
i mean we can have a male in our
uh
species that is born
with i don't know w z
you know instead of x x y x y
he's born with w z
and or it whatever you want to call
and yeah there is a small percentage but
not because of that i think we can
say well then we can't define sex
i think uh for the for our practical
purposes in this case uh all we're
trying to figure out you know again is
if male and female can compete against
each other and i think for that uh using
the x x x y is just fine and if the guy
comes is is a fellow who changes sex
and goes fight with a woman well there's
two issues here one should he be be
allowed to fight these women
is is this fellow a he or a she
just because he changes sex especially
at the age of 30 35 like in this case
and the other one is why not why can't
he fight should we all fight against
each other if you're going to talk about
professionalism right and yeah most uh
people don't go and fight and most
people don't become gladiators okay so
it's just for those people who want to
make money want to make a career out of
it should they be
allowed to fight anyone against anyone
everyone against everyone you know
uh you know in video games i don't play
these video games but i've seen my kids
play quite a bit
and
you see females with all these
superpowers fighting against males
you know the characters they put on
there on the screen are females
why should we limit that to video games
only where the female
has all these super powers and throws
you know this energy or whatever
nonsense they've got in those video
games
well why limit it to
to the video game why not have it in
real life why don't we go out there
and uh fight in real life you know male
against women male against female
any problem with that i mean is there
something wrong with that a lot of
females might say well that's unfair
well what's unfair about it i mean there
are females out there within a given
weight category that are more skilled
than a male and will beat them and so
you'll have this ranking and maybe the
first 10 will be males and may the 11th
will be a female
and then over time you know you'll have
maybe the fifth one will be a female
maybe the
further on maybe the second one will be
a female i mean can can that happen
okay that's the question
and if if that can happen why not have
unisex sports why limited to everything
else
and yeah i mean we don't have equality
certainly in birthing i mean we don't do
that they do that
okay so yeah we don't have perfect
equality but again it's just a question
of
people who want to become
professionals who want to make a career
out of it
maybe they should just run against mail
against them
fight against them the whole works all
sports
okay teams male teams against female
teams why why not just make it intersex
you know completely mixed mixed against
mixed we do it in softball don't we i
mean i've seen i played softball and we
played it with
mixed
teams
uh we did also i played with uh
you know not professionally obviously
volleyball you know mixed teams
what's different uh about a woman in
that sense i mean she can hit the ball
just as much as any male right
okay and some are even more skilled than
a lot of males so
yeah
okay um so this comes down really to to
this uh issue about chromosomes and dna
and our genetic code
and one of the issues there is that uh
this article that i saw
in um i think it was berkeley
and says and as an endangered species
dwindles it loses genetic variation
okay but it says as a species dwindles
okay now keep that in mind and even if
the species rebounds okay like you see
there the blue line going back up
population increases okay
says its level of genetic variation will
not
okay
so
even if the population rebounds okay
doesn't mean they're going to recover uh
genetic variation they're still going to
have very low genetic variation why
because genetic variation will only
slowly be restored through the
accumulation of mutations over many
generations
for this reason an endangered species
where low genetic variation may risk
extinction long after its population
size has recovered
okay so yeah i think
you have this situation where for
example humans we've lost quite a bit of
genetic diversity over the centuries we
have a relatively low genetic diversity
considering that we're eight billion
people on the planet
and the geneticists don't really know
what's happening
but here you have a clue these people
saying you know you can lose genetic
variation over time but usually when the
population dwindles in the case of man
you know we have lots of population but
very little genetic diversity you know
uh
some monkeys out there some chimps
in africa as i showed the
previous uh lectures have more genetic
diversity you know maybe 50 100 chimps
than all of the human race
how can that possibly be here you have a
small group they have more genetic
diversity than all of the human race
and
again i'm saying that we lost genetic
diversity over time and what's the
problem that i see with this well it's
not focused properly because what they
when they talk about extinction in this
context
they go completely off on left field you
know uh they go on a tangent and what's
the tangent here it is here's the
comment that follows this and it goes
something like this says the risk of
extinction or population decline because
of low genetic variation is predicted by
evolutionary theory okay great
epidemics could sweep through a species
with low genetic variation increasing
their chances of extinction
in other words what are these
geneticists talking about what they're
saying is that a species that has very
low genetic diversity
uh is um
is is in danger of becoming extinct only
because
uh they could get a disease
for which they have no uh defenses
that's the argument okay
and i'm saying that has absolutely
nothing to do with anything okay
this is where they make their
error
no species ever died because of disease
disease doesn't kill species
okay
and so when these people talk about oh
you know they have very low genetic
diversity if a disease comes over kills
them all or kills many of them that's
not the issue the issue is that when you
have low genetic diversity you are
inbreeding you're going to produce
garbage
as children
you're going to produce what we see
today among humans yeah we're not
producing good stock now
and uh there are many parameters among
them you know low sperm counts etc etc
there are many
clues that we're not producing good
children today so the children that
we're producing today
are not of the quality that we had 200
300 years ago they're not of the same
quality because we've been inbreeding
it's like you know the
kings of
russia you know the the
sars
and they had hemophilia because they
inbred
uh i showed also that the
charles ii of spain he was from the
habsburg family
and they all intermarried and eventually
it came down to charles ii several
generations after
you know the founders
and he he was born you know uh he they
called him a bewitched because he had
mental problems
and he was born like that
and so you know a lot of these uh
interm inbreeding is what really is the
problem
and you can't have a species live on
forever in breeding and expect not to
have at some point some genetic problems
and i'm saying all these
genetic problems that we have today are
related to the fact that we've been
inbreeding that's where the danger is
not in the fact that we're
um
susceptible to diseases
that's that's the least of our problems
the problem is that we're we're all
marrying each other and whoever you
marry today is either your brother your
sister from a genetic point of view when
you do that it's the same thing that
happened to the sars and so on the
habsburgs what you're doing is
you're having two people who have the
same genetic code and they have children
nothing good is going to come out of
there and you see that also with the
amish amish they're also having problems
genetic problems why because they've
been in breeding for about 300 years now
that's the issue
so it's not an issue of that you are now
more susceptible to catch a disease for
which you have no defenses
okay it's it's the other ones the fact
that you're gonna produce children with
genetic problems
that's my argument okay
okay uh here's uh another fountain says
estranged
estrogenization of the environment is
bound to change human sexual identity
and behavior
so there we have the sandman he's
pouring all this estrogen in the
environment okay
well you know there are studies but
those studies are based on lab
experiments and those are very
controlled experiments where they
you know pollute the environment but to
think that estrogen is floating around
that's uh you know a far cry i think uh
you know uh you can't extract you can't
generalize from what you see in an
experiment okay
so yeah you know you have these uh
environmental problems and i put little
weight on environmental problems i say
that more most of our problems have to
do with inbreeding but the fact that
we've lost genetic diversity and we keep
inbreeding you know
just marrying our own type
and eventually you know
that's got to produce some problems and
i think that's what we're seeing out
there today okay
i think a lot of these problems are
genetic or from a genetic point of view
and we're not going to overcome them i
think it can only get worse there's no
way you can undo what we're doing now
okay
another file says the word
sustainability is code word for the
globalist like the handshake for the
mesons
when one combines this when one combines
this information with a revolutionary
counter-revolutionary new constitution
which acknowledges climate change
same-sex marriage presumption of
innocence and god forbid private
property there is only one conclusion we
are entering the age of great
convergence cuba will become more and
more like the u.s and the u.s will
become more like cuba the end is near as
you foretold
[Laughter]
okay
yeah one of the things that you see in
the world and i think it does reflect
quite a bit on
extinction
the fact that all countries are becoming
more uniform in the type of governments
they have
it's a mixture it's not communism and
it's not capitalism not any longer now
it's all mixed systems some parts of the
economy are handled in a socialistic
manner
perhaps health like here in germany
for sure education
more or less everywhere
what is it disability unemployment
retirement all those things are handled
in a socialistic fashion on the other
hand you have also capitalism communism
china is not a communist country under
no circumstances all they ask
about communism is it's its name
other than that you know china is just
the same as the united states it has
you know one party in the united states
there's only one party with two names in
china has only one name that's the only
difference but other than that it's the
same thing you have a ruling group
and those people live well and then you
have the people at the bottom
majority of them right
and
way at the bottom they're poor in the
middle you got the middle class that
that's the same almost in every country
it's just that different countries have
different levels of income and so that
pyramid doesn't always look have the
same shape in all countries in some
countries the middle class is a little
bigger or quite a bit bigger than in
other countries that's the only
difference other than that they all have
this pyramid structure
so uh you know
there is no communism and capitalism in
that sense and if you go to cuba in many
ways you'll find it that it's like the
united states you say is that so yeah
i'm telling you i've been there several
times and
there's a black market out on the
streets
rugged capitalism right on the streets
and people trade and they do their thing
and nobody can control so so many uh
transactions going on on the streets the
only problem with cuba they've got
nothing to trade in general you know
uh other than that you know people are
the same everywhere people like to trade
and they like to have things
and they want to have things you know
and so whether it's communist or
capitalism it doesn't matter people
trade and and they want and they get
things that they want so there is not
that much difference between countries
okay they all have a you call it
capitalist slash communist
economy society
uh you wanna call it socialism you wanna
call it um
center left
whatever you want to call it it's the
same thing they all have more or less
the same system
very little difference and dictatorships
are
a question of um how much you really
know i mean you know you you go to north
korea and say well that's a dictatorship
well
what is a dictatorship that they control
the armed forces and they control the
news that reaches you
and the resources
what's different with other countries
people in every country have the same
problem you know they're not the ones
who rule they don't have the power and
they have to live with what's
essentially given to them whatever is
available to them according to their
income and in that sense they are slaves
you know the people way at the bottom so
so there's very little difference really
the only difference is some countries
are richer than others
and so they can afford to give their
population something more than other
countries so if you take country in
africa almost any of them compare them
against germany here yeah the level of
income here is much higher okay
and so
people are not in in as bad as shape as
in other countries other than that
there's a pyramid here and there's a
pyramid over there the pyramid over
there is just a little lower that's all
it is quite a bit lower in some cases
but other than that there's always a
pyramid people at the top and powerful
people who
control the money the resources the law
the news
and those at the bottom that are on the
receiving end
that's about it
okay let's move on to
the subject matter today which is the
existence of time
and what i'm gonna do today i'm gonna
start my lecture with a little um
magic trick
okay
so i hope you're ready for this okay i'm
gonna perform a magic trick that's never
been done in the history of humanity
okay
you've seen it here first okay i'm gonna
make
time
disappear
now how's that for a magic trick
okay you've seen it here first
or
maybe you did not see it because there's
not going to be much to see okay but
bear with me okay
this is my hat my top hat okay
and i'm gonna
first to show that you know i am a
magician because you got to show your
credentials
up front okay what i'm gonna do is what
every magician has to learn the first
day of class and that is you have to
make a rabbit disappear
okay
so so first thing you got to do as a
magician is know how to make a rabbit
disappear if you can't do that you're
not a magician
okay that's like the abcs
okay so i show the hat you see there's
nothing in there okay
okay and i take my rabbit okay
here
hold still button
shaking there you know uh you know you
ask why do i grab the bunny by the ears
his name is bugs by the way
because
you know that's the best way to handle a
rabbit they scratch they kick around
hold on bunny okay here let's put them
in there okay okay
okay
easy now easy now i'm gonna make you
disappear now okay don't don't get
excited
okay so here goes
abracadabra
the rabbit disappeared
okay
no more rabbit
okay
having done that trick now let's move to
the real trick
i'm gonna make time disappear okay
next trick so
there's nothing in there yeah i hope you
can see there's nothing in there
okay i'm gonna grab a little bit of time
here
got a lot of time on my hand okay
pour it in there i sprinkled it
okay
and i say
alla peanut butter sandwich
salam
and time disappeared
okay
yeah these are great tricks
but um you know what i found over the
years
is that it's pretty easy to make
things disappear
especially if they're not there to begin
with
you know but the other thing i learned
and that a lot of magicians
will agree with me is that you know you
can make a rabbit reappear
you know you can make them disappear now
you make them up here yeah you can make
them reappear you know i i for example i
can take the rabbit and even turn them
into a clock if i want okay
i can turn them into an elephant once
you know the trick you know you can turn
them into anything i mean you've seen it
probably with other magicians as well
they take a little animal or you know
maybe a rabbit and they produce an
elephant on stage
that's easy to do
what i've never seen and you'll never
see because i haven't learned how to do
that yet
is to make time reappear
once time disappears
you know
i don't know the trick to make it
reappear
like i would with a rabbit
so all i can tell you is that um
i'm working on it whenever i find out a
way of making time
reappear
i will perform the trick here on stage
directly to you okay but as of today i
don't know anyone who can make time
reappear okay
okay having said that let's do a little
recap
of what we did these days these last few
days and we went over distance
started with distance and find out that
we have distance traveled which belongs
to math
not the physics whereas distance
separation belongs to physics and not to
math because it's a qualitative concept
okay that's the first thing we noticed
uh yeah
what is
distance traveled just amount traveled
in a period of time what is uh
distance for physics just separation gap
okay
that's
all we see the separation between two
objects
okay uh and in in mathematics okay
mathematics as we call it
distance traveled is equal to position
equal to displacement e to the equal to
length they're all dynamic concepts all
four of those are dynamic concepts not
one of them is a static concept okay i
talked about that the other day so you
can look at the previous video
velocity is equal to speed
plus direction
the problem with that is that
direction belongs strictly to physics
direction is a qualitative concept
you know a mathematician can't put
direction and put it in the equation
what's he going to do with it okay so
you can't use direction in
mathematics and yet you know when they
talk about velocity they talk about
direction in fact you won't hear very
much the term velocity of light usually
they talk about the speed of light
okay because uh if it's velocity of
light it turns the corner and now the
question is has it accelerated and
people say well no all it did is change
direction yeah but direction belongs to
physics first of all and second i showed
the other day that you still have this
uh centripetal motion
acceleration
and that's called acceleration
and the way they calculate velocity
which is a single point in space and
time meaning single location meaning a
cross section of time is
by
uh performing uh the derivative you know
by going by calculating it so we don't
have a value we don't have a measured
value really for velocity it's
calculated even with the little device
that you use to measure that
okay
and then we went to time we started time
the other day and we have uh what is
time distance traveled divided by speed
but you have to add direction because
remember they say that time
moves forward
moves forward
is forward a direction
i mean you know is my forward the same
as your forward
is my uh time going in that direction
and yours is coming in my direction what
direction does time
flow
is there a flow of time uh is there
something flowing like a river
you know so what happens is that uh in
physics
we don't use the word time at all
except when we talk about before and
after earlier later
yesterday and tomorrow in the sense of
just you know
sequential time other than that
qualitative time other than that we have
no use for time at all we don't use time
in physics
okay time is strictly a word that
belongs to
mathematics okay seconds and all that
stuff we don't care about that in
physics because in physics we're only
going to explain
a mechanism
and we have no use for seconds or
minutes or years to explain a mechanism
okay
uh we don't talk about a year we talk
about an orbit maybe you know
planet
orbits the sun we say one orbit two
orbits that's fine with us okay we don't
need really
seconds and minutes
okay so uh what do we have well in um
in physics what they've put there this
tense triangle divided by speed that's
just motion divided by motion in other
words what you have is a comparison of
two motions and that is the definition
that we have for time
now it turns out that um
in uh mathematical physics what these
people do is
they turn time into a physical object
okay
and what they do with time they stretch
it they slow it down they speed it up
they talk about flowing that flows they
talk about warping it
they're talk they talk about
traveling through time like if time were
a medium
so in mathematical physics they treat at
all times when they give a physical
interpretation
they always treat time as a physical
object as a substance as a medium as a
thing
okay
and so they do their presentation you
ask them at the end you know the
reporter said okay uh
are you saying that at the end of the
presentation right are you saying that
time is a physical object that it's a
medium it's a substance
of course not
what did you think that
i mean you're taking all the analogies
too literally
and you say well hold it then what was
the purpose of the analogy if you were
giving me a physical interpretation
saying that the earth doesn't fly out of
the solar system because time is warped
and the skin of the earth comes up
against the warpage of time
and that's preventing the earth from
flying out that's the analogy you gave
me you treated time as a physical object
when i asked
is time really a physical object like a
wall
and you say no you're taking the analogy
too literally
well then what was the purpose of the
analogy
i mean it's time a physical object or
not
and it turns out for the physical
interpretations time is always an object
but when you put the mathematicians
against the ropes and begin pummeling
him with questions
that's when he says well of course time
is not an object
and so we have this circular argument
this contradiction this duality as
mathematicians like to call them okay
and here's a proof evidence
okay that that is the case here we have
mr brian greene
and he had a little show i think it was
2004
and
in that show
fabric of the cosmos he talked about
time in the second installment there
were like three installments the second
one dealt with time and this is what he
says okay this is what
mr green okay
uh
who i don't know what planet he comes
from because he says all these things
that
you would think do not come from an
intelligent person at all okay
says contrary to everyday experience
time may not flow at all he was talking
about flow he says time doesn't flow but
what he does next is he freezes the
river
okay
and um
he says no it doesn't flow because it's
solid so he turns it into a physical
object anyways then he says it turns out
that time itself can be
speeded up or slowed down gravity can
pull on time slowing its passage
so you can see all these statements
treat time as a physical object he talks
about the direction of time what's the
direction forward that's the way that's
the direction in which it moves he talks
about the arrow of time again giving it
direction giving it this forward
direction
and he ends his presentation by saying
that
the future
exists
he talks about the existence of time
so now we have a little bit of problem
because every one of these statements
show that he's treating it as a physical
object
and of course when you confront him and
you say well hold it uh brian are you
saying that
time is a physical object it flows you
can bend it you can warp it you can
stretch it you can make it go faster or
slower it's a medium through which you
travel
you're treating as a physical object
and so let's make sure that that's what
he's saying so here's here's a summary
of what he said there okay
these are the different things he says
time flows okay or is fl uh it's a river
that's frozen one or two because he
walks on this frozen river later on
time is a structure but let's look at
flow first here's what he says about um
the flowing river okay it says like a
river's time seems to flow endlessly
from one moment to the next and the flow
of time seems to always be in one
direction towards the future
oh which
in which direction does the future
uh is the future that's what i'd like to
know i mean can he point to the future
okay so this is the problem he treats it
like a river he says it's um it's uh it
flows then he says well we can freeze it
and maybe time is more like a frozen
river where the future in the past
exists and we walk towards the future
meaning it's got direction
okay so so yeah he's treating it as a
physical object it's not that i want to
make sure people
don't conclude that i'm inventing all
this stuff then he says time is equal to
a structure and here's uh his comment on
that he says uh
time is some kind of
thingy okay it says um
see if we started here so with the
discovery of this unexpected link
between space and time
it says they're fused together into a
four-dimensional what structure called
space-time
he thinks it's a structure and he's this
is a four-dimensional meaning you cannot
even imagine this structure but he does
talk about structure of space-time
okay and so
the the question here is
he's saying he's using it as a physical
object and then if you put him against
the wall and say well are you saying
that time is a physical object of course
he'll deny it
but here he's using it as a physical
object so is time a physical object or
not
i mean it's black or white either it is
or not if it's not
then what is the purpose of the analogy
of using all these analogies
he says it's a work by gravity this
thing okay here it is here's the his
statement on how gravity warps
time meaning you know like you work a
hammock when you sit on it okay that's
how he's treating time here okay here it
is
says uh well let's see where it starts
here give it a second
starts here says einstein theory show
that gravity like motion can affect time
great
okay and he says it says if gravity can
pull on time slowing its passage
okay the stronger the gravitational pull
the more time slows if you could travel
to a black hole the effect of gravity on
time would be huge
okay so what does he say saying there's
a concept called gravity
and this concept has the ability to
affect time physically because he's
talking about slowing time down
i didn't even know that time was
speeding up or going fast or going
anywhere
and here this guy is saying look if time
is going fast don't worry just put a
little gravity in there sprinkle it in
there like i did you know today with my
top hat and you can slow it down
okay so this is what what these folks
are saying and so you're saying well you
know
are they giving you a figure of speech
or something or is this an analogy a
simile what is this
what kind of physical interpretation is
this to say that gravity slows time down
is is time running fast
okay
and uh
and then he ends this thing saying time
exists
how can time exist here he
says give it a second here we'll go from
the start
and he looks like a little choir boy uh
you know from the monastery once we know
that you're now can be what i consider
the passer your now can be what i
consider the future
and your now is every bit as valid as
mine now
then we learn that the past must be real
the future must be real they could be
your now
i like his faces because he looks like a
born-again mathematician
he says they
all exist past present and future all
equally real they all exist
so he's saying that time exists
that's what he's saying he's saying the
past present and future in this uh
big um
what is it blocked universe that uh
these people like to talk about he says
time exists that's what that block
universe is it's a single chunk of
frozen water it's not flowing
and you can find the future and the past
all in that block and all you have to do
of course is if you want to travel to
the future just take your
uh what is it your rocket and somehow
reach that destination in the future
this is what these people are saying
okay
okay um
so
does he treat it as a physical object
of course he does in every statement
that he's got in that video and he's not
the only one by the way i'm picking on
him but they're all the same they all
tell you that time is a thing they treat
as a thing
you know and so you say well this time a
thing
what if we ask people out there what do
they think the time is how would they
define it what notions do people have of
time
so i went into quora and found out you
know but before that you know to compare
we have mr um
saint augustine and he says what then is
time he said this in the year 400 or
there about 397 400 a.d says what then
is time if no one asks me i know what it
is
okay if i wish to explain it to him who
asked i do not know
and here we are what is it
16 1700 years later
and people still don't have any idea
what time is these are some of the
answers in quora there were 100 so i
didn't get them all
but you can see some of the first ones
that are out there says time is motion
one fellow says not one says the
interval between successive events
another one says no one can exactly
describe time as such
another one says we literally don't know
what time is
another one repeats the first one says
detectable measurable change
another one says there is no greed
definition of time
and the other one finally says time is
what a clock measures anyone who claims
to know any more than this is either
lying or deluded
okay so those are the notions of time do
we have any idea what time is of course
not none of these people have any idea
what time is because they try to define
it in terms of their religion when you
introduce religion you want to hold on
to your religion you're going to end up
with lousy definitions
okay that's the problem
okay so we asked the question these are
the this is the only real
important question these two questions
okay the first one
is time and object okay
this time in a physical object is time
of thing
and you know those are synonyms so that
you don't use that in the definition if
you're going to define it you can't use
the word entity medium substance
structure any of those because those are
synonyms of thing okay
so you can't use those words it but is
it a thing
this time a thing
and for that you know you need to define
what a thing is so that you can answer
that question and the other one is does
time exist
okay
can we say that time exists
and a lot of people would say that time
is not a thing
but time exists
that would be their i think the majority
of people 90 of the people out there at
least would answer that question that
way they would say time is not an object
okay but time exists
that's what i think people would answer
okay so let's find out what an object is
because we need to find out what an
object is to be able to answer the
question before we can answer whether
time is an object we need to find out
what an object is so let's make sure we
at least eliminate it as an object
scientifically okay so here let's
eliminate it complete okay
object that which has shape
okay you don't like the definition no
problem you come up with a better mouse
trap that's your job
you know you got to find out what's
wrong with this definition what's good
about yours
otherwise this definition sticks
okay
and yeah no we don't use um
tradition
we don't raise our hands and vote that's
not the way it works in science we don't
say well this is the way we've always
done it this is what every person on
earth believes that an object is we
don't care about any of that this is
what we've i found in the dictionary and
copied and pasted none of that is
scientific now in science we we
defend our definition we put a
definition up there you don't like it
put a better one up there and
show what's wrong with this one and put
yours and show what's good about yours
that's how it works
shape is the only universal property of
objects all objects have shape okay
there is no object you can imagine that
does not have shape so it's a universal
property and that's a good point to
define the word object in terms of shape
okay
and we have the golden principle physics
you can't do physics without an object
because physics requires an object what
would there be to study if or or analyze
or anything if there were no objects in
the universe every all we had was empty
space
okay so you have to have some object for
a phenomenon to happen
it is irrational to use concepts as
objects in physics known as the fallacy
of reification you cannot use a concept
like love
and turn it into a heart
or take intelligence and turn it into a
brain
or take grace and turn it into god or
whatever okay you can't do that not in
physics in ordinary speech you can get
away with all that stuff it's in physics
in science that you can't do that okay
in ordinary speech you can say whatever
you want
okay if time is deemed to be a concept
okay
this word cannot be used as an object in
the course of a physical interpretation
okay
so if time is an object under that
definition
shape
well all you have to tell me is what
does time look like you should be able
to draw it okay if you if you think that
time has shape
if time does not have shape we have
rejected it officially scientifically
as a um
as a as an object
it stays as a concept there are only two
possibilities every word in the
dictionary is either an object or a
concept
if it's not an object because time does
not have shape we're done
we're finished okay
time is not an object
okay according to that definition he who
doesn't like the definition has to come
up with a better mousetrap again has to
defend his definition and show what's
wrong with this one
that's it that's all they got to do very
simple actually right
okay and uh so the next issue is
existence okay
does time exist
okay and so
here we have a sequence of definitions
that we need to answer that question the
first one is what is an object an object
that which has shape what is distance
well it's separation between two objects
what is location it's a set of distances
from one object to all the rest
in the system or in the world or in the
universe right
and what is a concept it's a word that
invokes or embodies two objects you need
two objects a relation between two
objects to have a concept
so either
every word in the dictionary is either a
concept meaning that you have a relation
there between
made by a human obviously usually right
i mean a lion i guess can have concepts
in his mind to some degree right
and
the opposite is the object and the best
way to look at that is does it have
shape does it not have shape if it has
shape it's an object we're done if it
doesn't have shape
it's a concept
we're done as well
okay
and so what does exist well the
definition is physical presence
okay what is uh physical stands for
object what is presence for location
it's an object that has location what
was location the set of distances to all
other objects then we can say that
the object exists
and as you can see uh concepts are not
allowed
to exist no concept can be said to exist
in physics
in order ordinary speech you can say
that love exists we don't care about
that that's religion that's just you
know nonsense talk
in physics only objects can be said to
exist and in order to exist they have to
have
uh location with respect to other
objects
so if you are imagining a table
that table is an object because it has
shape
but it has no distance with respect to
any other object because it's an
imaginary table
okay so let's keep the right context
there in mind okay so we have a
definition for exist and again you don't
have to agree with any of these
definitions if you don't like them you
have only one
recourse and that's to get inside the
ring with your shield with your sword
fight for your definition and show
what's wrong with these definitions
either individually or as a whole
okay so uh what do we conclude here we
will say time is not an object because
time does not have shape
uh shape of a concept
irrational no concept has shape and time
does not have location
first because it's not an object and so
you can't have it's a concept and then
second you know concepts don't have
shape so you can't establish a distance
with respect to anything therefore it
doesn't have location
okay these location is a set of
distances what are the conclusions time
is not an object time has no location
time is a concept and pursuant to the
definition of exists that you see up
there time does not exist
in physics
in ordinary speech and religion you can
say whatever you want you can say god
exists
in uh if you're going to talk rationally
you're going to talk in this the world
of science if you want to step over the
line into physics and that's what you do
when you use the word exist in any way
shape or form
then if you want to show that you know
your theory you want to prove your
theory you want people to believe in
your theory hey come over here we'll
we'll take care of your definitions
first
and if you don't have a good definition
for exist that you can match against
these well you got to accept these
definitions otherwise you got to come up
with a better mousetrap and so you can
say well i believe that god exists yeah
or the other guy might say i don't
believe that god exists well you haven't
said anything until you define and exist
let alone god
so we need to define the word exist then
we can figure out whether god exists or
not and the same thing with time does
time exist well what do you mean by
exist
what do you mean is time and object
what do you mean by object so first we
need to define the words object and
exist then we can use the terms
consistently in our dissertation and say
time is an object or time is not an
object time exists or time does not
exist we can say because now we have
definitions that we can you know stand
upon we have
laid the foundations to be able to talk
about time in a rational manner okay to
another human being
okay so here are some corollaries okay
from these definitions okay here it is
objects we point to
because they have shape you should be
able to point to an object even the one
in your head because all you have to do
is
draw what you have in your head outside
and then you can point to what you were
thinking of so you can present that to a
jury you can present that to
a
in a conference you can say well what
are you thinking of what do you think
light is well i think this is light you
can show them what you think it is maybe
a series of particles maybe a wave
or maybe a rope right
concepts we define
so if you can define it it's not an
object
okay let's repeat that because that goes
through a lot of people's head and then
out the other door right
concepts we define if you can define a
word it's not an object it can't be an
object object we point to in physics in
science
in ordinary speech you can do whatever
you want not important at all we're
talking about science here
objects you should be able to point to
because the only property all objects
have the universal property is shape
do they exist well if it has location
now it exists by definition not because
you believe or stop believing but
because by definition okay it has
location
and then if you can define the word time
then time is a concept
and yeah we're gonna try to define the
word time but here's uh some more
corollaries if you have more rational
definition for these strategic terms
don't copy and paste definitions you
find in dictionaries of ordinary speech
this just means that you haven't
challenged or understood these
definitions
and accepted them rather on the basis of
authority tradition and democracy
meaning majority vote you're just
looking
behind you to find out if all these
mathematicians
mathematicians are behind you and stand
behind you i don't care if the whole 8
billion people stand behind you it
doesn't matter it doesn't make it right
you can all be flat earthers and it
doesn't make the earth flat okay
you are doing religion that's what
you're doing
and proponents must defend the rationale
behind their proposals in other words
you gotta get in the ring with your
shield and sword and fight like a man
okay don't be a coward don't run away
don't tell me this is what they told you
this is what how they educated you that
you found it in a dictionary that
everybody believes in your definition
none of that matters
the only way is to get inside the ring
attack the definitions you saw there
and
defend the ones you have that's the only
way there is no other way so don't look
behind you there's no one else in this
island except you and me okay
there's no one
no one's gonna back you up and if they
do it seem irrelevant anyways
okay so one fellow gave gave time a try
okay he says the definition of time time
is change he says
or the interval over which change occurs
if a system is unchanging it is timeless
okay
we only need something that repeats
predictably to have a measurement of
time
okay let's find out all the errors this
file may he made so many errors only in
in that
small
piece of you know sequence of statements
here the
the uh
errors with all that okay
interval is a synonym of time okay what
is an integral you look it up an
intervening period of time so you can't
use the word interval to define time
change is equal to motion but motion is
not equal to time they're not synonyms
motion and time are a little bit
different
okay
time requires more than just change
so far all you have is motion and time
requires memory
motion does not
move you move by definition you have two
locations okay you don't have to
memorize the previous one all you have
to do is by definition you have to have
two locations
but uh time you have to have a
comparison of two motions you have to
memorize your origin of each one of the
objects that you're comparing okay or
you could have it even you know
the same object uh compared to a
a
another uh
chunk of uh itinerary for that same
object but you're comparing essentially
two objects even when you do that so
what you're doing is comparing two
motions
and for that you need to
memorize the origin of those two motions
and compare them later on you know when
you finally
reach the end of those two motions and
you're comparing them
and yeah so um here's uh here's a clear
definition of time okay
and it's uh we have qualitative time a
relation established between two
locations of an object or between the
trajectories of two objects
okay there you see what it is okay um
what you see is the earth going around
the sun that's how they more or less
establish the first second or one of the
first seconds they had several seconds
throughout history okay several ways of
measuring it but it had to do with the
orbit of the earth around the sun
and what are we doing when we talk about
a second well originally right because
today we have a different standard for
the second but for many centuries what
we had is that the second was
essentially
the movement of
the hand on the clock or it could be any
other
compared against the
motion of the earth around the sun what
they did was they took the orbit of the
earth and chopped it up into days and
then into
hours and minutes and seconds and they
ended up with the second
and we built our clocks based on that we
said okay when that hand on the clock
moves from one tick to the other the
earth went 30 kilometers around the sun
that's essentially what a second is the
comparison of two motions okay now you
have the quantitative time that
mathematics use okay we don't care about
that you can read it later on but that
essentially uh gives you an idea of what
uh time is conceptually from a
conceptual
point of view it's a comparison of two
motions and for that you absolutely need
memory okay you can't do time without
memory
okay incidentally let me
point out a couple
issues here
what is the cgs the centimeter gram
[Music]
second metric system or you can call it
also the kilogram meter meter kilogram
second system second doesn't change what
changes is the meter the killer only
okay but uh you know
when you have a meter like you know
here i have a meter okay
let me take this out of here so you can
see it better
okay
here you have a meter well uh just a
measuring stick okay
and uh or
you have this you know the uh
the to measure
um
you know whatever you want any meters or
whatever but you have a a standard
called a meter once you have that
standard you can put that standard
anywhere you want okay because it's a
physical standard
and for the kilogram the same thing you
have a chunk of whatever you know you
can have a chunk of lead
and you can call it the meter you can
guard the center i'm sorry you can call
it the kilogram or the gram or you can
call it you know maybe in the land of
the klingons they call it the x whatever
that unit is you have a chunk of
something
and that's going to be your standard
because you arbitrarily designated that
as your standard
but for the second we have no physical
object
okay there is no physical what are you
measuring okay
this is the issue there's no physical
object when you're measuring when you're
measuring time okay
time is actually calculated again
originally as a
segment or piece of the orbit of the
earth and today they do it with the
cesium uh
wavelength right
but essentially you're measuring that's
it but it but there's no physical
standard for time whereas you have a
physical standard for the meter and you
have a physical standard for the
kilogram which are the three main ones
for the uh metric system the foundation
okay and uh
because these people never define their
terms you know these mathematicians they
don't know what time it is but they use
it they tell you that they bend time
that they warp it that they
travel through it
that they can make it go slower fast
depending on how much gravity there is
or mass or whatever
and because they they have all these
they never define time but they use it
and they tell you that can they treat it
as a physical object then they
take back everything they said at the
end of the story and say well no time is
not a physical object then you don't
know what to think they have all these
weird things but it turns out that one
of the things that the mathematicians
tell you
is that um the universe is expanding
why because you have this big bang that
happened 13.7 or 8
billion years ago
and since then there's been this
expansion
the expansion of what what's been
expanding well the universe has been
expanding and is expanding that's what
they tell you and then in another
context they tell you the universe is
infinite
space is infinite time is infinite i
mean where does time end
doesn't time continue forever
and they say well the universe is
infinite they like to say that like
saying you know
they leave it be beyond your
comprehension that's why they use the
word infinite so they say
here's infinity you know time
expanding
and it turns out that here you have
infinity expanding this is so weird
because uh we have a contradiction there
okay we have this is their logic the
universe is infinite
nothing is outside of space
okay meaning it's really finite but they
say it's infinite but it's a
wrong question to ask what's outside of
space or a space-time and then they tell
you that
this infinity is expanding
and what is pushing it outwards well
it's uh this thing called dark energy
what is preventing it from expanding
faster well it's this pull of gravity
which they call dark matter
so we have dark matter fighting against
dark energy dark matter pulls inwards
and the universe wants to expand against
what against nothing because it's
infinite
and we have this infinity that's
expanding time which is expanding
you figure it out
okay let's get to the uh questions that
we had since last time
and we have a fellow here and he asked
the following he says you said the links
of a right straight tight straight rope
are shorter at both far ends while at
the middle of the rope the links are
longer yeah this is uh what i think is
happening okay i'm proposing that the
links of taut wires on utility post or
what you call the telephone posts in
your video are not that different from
each other
well not that different means they are
different
okay so it's it's black or white either
they are different or they're not that
different meaning they are different
okay let's make sure you understand your
own language you can simply observe
people who play tug of war and see
whether the links of that rope change
drastically or not
drastically means they changed
it's a black or white issue did they
change did they not change so again uh
the fellow doesn't understand the words
that he's using there
they have changed
all you're talking about is degree of
change
okay
what you're trying to say is the
electromagnetic ropes are similar to
macro level rubber thread absolutely not
uh the the thread is made of a single
piece so it doesn't stretch okay
uh and so it's not a rubber thread let's
clarify that
where when we stretched it out the
middle of the rubber thread become
longer while both of the far ends of the
rubber threads remain the same
i don't know what kind of brain this
poor fella has now uh what we're saying
here is that uh you know if you take a
rope
and you stretch it all the way to the
moon
as you get farther and farther away from
the earth the links will tend to be
longer that's what we're saying no
stretching necessary just that you have
towards the center they're going to
unwind a little more than uh then closer
to the source
and so this is not an issue of
stretching it's an issue of un
untwisting okay
so
you know where you got this i don't know
uh but then this begs the question now
are you talking about a single thread
can actually stretch no they they don't
stretch okay
and your website you keep saying a
single thread can't be stretched correct
can't be stretched and here you see it
in the hardware tower experiment okay
here it is uh more or less uh at the
bottom okay where
there was a source and as the wave uh
went to the top of the tower they were
able to measure cross-section okay
cross-section of the rope
they were able to measure that uh the
rope was
tighter at the bottom than at the top
very little difference again very little
difference but enough difference that
they were able to measure that
difference uh and again with any rope
you can probably see that just take a
rope and stretch it to the other side of
the universe and you'll see if the links
remain the same
do the links have the same
uh length and i'm telling you they won't
and so again this fall talks about
uh drastically no it's not a question of
drastically that's a question of how
much we're not talking about how much
we're saying they will
not have the same link length okay
so that's the only thing he's got to
understand there
okay another follow-up says
definition of object a material thing
that can be seen and touched okay a
requirement to meet this definition
material is three-dimensional
shape has nothing to do with being an
object
although objects have shape sounds like
a contradiction because if objects have
shape
then apparently that's the definition of
object but then he tries to secure he
says not all shapes are object well i
don't know until we have a definition we
don't know and so let's find out what's
wrong with this definition why we can't
use that in science it's relegated to
religion to ordinary speech no chance
whatsoever in science and here are the
problems the first one is material
material is a substance that constitutes
an object what is substance an object a
thing what is object a thing an object
so you can't use the word material
because you're using a synonym to define
the word object and same for matter
there you can see the same things the
same words okay then you have the word
thing synonym of object okay so you
can't say a material thing because thing
is what an object is that's the word
we're trying to define
so the word material already embodies
the word object and the word thing is a
synonym of object so you can't use
either one of those two words
then you have a bigger problem here
scene he talks about scene and touch
scene is a verb and verbs require two
objects in this case you need the the
thing that is seeing and the thing that
is being seen so you need two objects to
have the word seen and nevertheless we
define the word object before we define
any verb because verb
an action is what objects do and the
same goes for the word touch it's a verb
that requires two objects in order to
have touch you need two objects sorry
okay so you can't you can't you can't do
touch without two objects you already
have a contradiction because you need
two objects to define the word object
uh as you're trying to do here okay so
yeah no no those that definition uh
probably copied and pasted it from some
ordinary dictionary and he wants to use
that in science no way you can't use
that definition it's not a scientific
definition okay here's a another issue
you made an observation to have an
assumption
[Laughter]
no no you don't need to observe anything
to make an assumption in fact you can't
listen what i'm telling you you can't
observe
to have an assumption okay and let me
tell you what i'm talking about okay
here's a my famous experiment it's
called the gravity experiment you let go
of the pen okay and it falls to the
table i do it again repeatable to be
scientific okay
again let go it falls to the table now
can you see
observe
what's here or up here is something
pushing the pen or something pulling on
the pen
can you see it can you observe it
can't you make an assumption about
what's invisible here that is coming in
contact with the skin of the pen
can't you make an assumption and say let
us assume
that there are a bunch of particles
pushing down on the pen
i can make that assumption
i don't need to see them i don't need to
observe i can observe the pen but i
can't observe the mechanism or the thing
that's coming in contact with the pen to
produce gravity
acceleration towards the center of the
earth
so i can't see or touch what's up here i
can't see your touch what's down here
but i can make an assumption and say
what if let us assume there are
particles pushing down i can make that
assumption i can also make an assumption
and say well what if every atom is
connected from
every one of these atoms to every atom
of the earth what if they're all
interconnected i can make that
assumption i don't have to see or touch
them
and so to make an assumption you do not
need to see in fact you can't observe
mother
nature's uh
mediators
for gravity for light
for uh magnetism you cannot observe them
you cannot see them so no you do not see
you can't see
the mediators mother nature uses you
have to make an assumption without
observing okay
and here you have a little um
put it over here
um
what the religion of mathematics says
okay what they do is they uh
they
use the word observe as the as a synonym
of the word proof
that's the context so when they say
observe they mean i proved it because i
observed it you can d you gotta deny
that i observed it and called me a liar
that's what they're saying okay
and yeah they
did a uh
faraday observe a magnetic field
did uh
rutherford uh
observe
the space the empty space between the
atom the nucleus and the electron
or did he just
make an assumption say let us assume
there's empty space in between there
and that and that's with that assumption
i can explain my theory of why
you know we have this
radiation come back when it hits the
nucleus and go through when it goes
through that empty space
so he was able to explain his theory
based on the assumption that the atom is
surrounded by mostly empty space that's
an assumption he never saw the empty
space for sure he didn't see the nucleus
he didn't see the electron he did not
observe any of that
it's a theory founded on the assumption
that an atom is mostly empty space did
stephen hawking stephen gawking did he
ever see a black hole
and he can't make an assumption he can't
say let us assume
that there is something called a black
hole
okay let's concede no problem
and we'll call it a ball
so there's a little ball with a lot of
mass gazillions of mass
gazillions of kilograms gazillions of
tons whatever you want to put in there
okay so we have this little ball
and it's got all this mass concentrated
in it
and now he says with that i can explain
the attraction of a star far away
because this has so much mass
as pulling on it or maybe it's weighing
down space time and this thing falls in
whatever the case may be did he observe
a black hole no the black hole is an
assumption he's saying let us assume
there's a black hole but again they turn
it around they say we proved it we took
a picture of it
we took a picture of a black hole oh you
did did you it turns out what they took
a picture of is some matter which they
claim rushed into a black hole
you know again they confuse the water
with a drain
okay the water is what they took a
picture of the drain they can't take a
picture of because it's zero dimensional
infinite mass etcetera etcetera okay so
keep that in mind and of course you know
the blind man he he can't he didn't see
the particles of light okay so he can
make an assumption say let us assume
that light is mediated
okay that light is
a sequence a series of particles okay he
makes that assumption he doesn't have to
see observe anything okay
so no we do not need to observe anything
in order to make assumptions
okay um here's uh another file says you
make up your own scientific definition
that doesn't include observation and
experimentation
well it's not that it doesn't matter who
comes up with it whether it's mine or
someone else okay the question is
do we have a scientific method that we
can live with and the question right now
is that we don't out there because these
people what they're doing is they're
saying okay i have a scientific method
okay apply it and they apply it and they
end up with
explanations or physical interpretations
where they say
a particle can be at two places at once
uh
gravity is the warping of space time
meaning two concepts
and so on down the line i mean i could
you know what is a black hole a zero
dimensional nothing that has infinite
mass and so on down the line big bang
the beginning of space
the creation of space not even god can
create space and here these people
created space from nothing whatever
nothing is and so on so you know it's on
and on and on what are the results the
results is we have no explanations today
for how this universe works these people
tell you in their face in your face that
they don't understand quantum mechanics
they don't understand relativity they
cannot explain it in a rational way they
say we don't understand it so all
they're doing is a bunch of math a bunch
of equations but they cannot turn that
into a physical interpretation
so what's the use of that so-called
scientific method that uh galileo and
newton all these great fellows of the
17th century came up with
and then we have the other issue that
you know when they came up with that
they overruled the greeks who had been
around for 2000 years
and now we're doing the same thing to
these people we're saying these 400
years were wasted because right now we
don't have a scientific method that
produces
physical interpretations
and so now it's time for these guys to
get out just like they got rid of the
classical greeks now we get rid of them
we say hey we don't need your your
so-called scientific method because it
hasn't produced any results we still
don't understand how this universe works
meaning causes mechanisms we have no
mechanism for gravity we have no
mechanism from mathematical physics we
have no mechanism from uh from
mathematical physics for magnetism we
have no mechanism for electricity or
light or the workings of the atom
okay so that's where we stand today
so how do we do it in science we say
rational explanations that's what we
need that's what science is we need a
rational explanation that's
that's science if you give me an
irrational explanation and a bunch of
equations that's not science okay and
you can't say well i ran an experiment
and observed and predicted
yeah
it's nonsense poppycock okay
okay so what is the explanation what is
rational well we have a definition for
those okay explain causes underlying a
phenomena
or how a consummated event happened
that's what we call an explanation in
physics i mean this is as applied to
physics that's what a theory is
and a theory is not an equation a theory
is not a mathematical
formula okay
theory is an explanation what is an
explanation causes underlying a
phenomena
what is rational irrational because you
know science is rational explanation
well we we define what irrational is and
you the number one is there you can't
treat a concept as a physical object for
a physical interpretation which is
exactly what mathematical physics does
so these people are always
always giving you physical
interpretations where they're redefining
concepts
and that's a no-no in science okay so
yeah uh
if if that's what a lot is allowed by
the scientific method of the 17th
century it's time for it to die to be
wiped out completely we don't need the
scientific method of newton and galileo
meaning experiments in math that's not
science that has only produced nonsense
we have no explanations science is not
just descriptions
science is explanations and they better
be rational
okay a couple more questions or issues
here one file says is a scientist
cheating the rsm the rational scientific
method if he or she makes a hypothesis
that some large mass of
computronium exists but with it makes a
theory that is essentially just a
description of the software that the
computer runs and claiming that it
explains a magical universe perhaps even
identical to the one proposed by the
establishment after all computers have
no problem with point particles uh bent
time waves and everything else
conceivable
yeah you can make an assumption of
anything
of anything just like you hear you can
make an assumption that god
uh sends his angels
to move the earth around the sun
you can make that assumption you can say
let us assume that god exists god is
that
human being there human-like
fellow okay has hands arms whatever he's
out there he's got a big head big big
intelligence a computer inside his brain
right
and he doesn't do the work he sends his
angel so here's um angel mark uh
archangel michael or whoever you know
and he takes the earth around the sun
and you have explained with that how the
earth goes around the sun
okay well that uh
has some challenges but certainly it's a
little more rational than what we get
from mathematical physics which says
that there's a concept called space-time
that somehow is pulled downwards it's a
surrealistic
vision because you know they're taking
this as a two-dimensional canvas
they're telling you it's a
four-dimensional canvas but they
illustrate a two-dimensional one to show
you why the earth goes around the sun
and you say why does the earth run out
of the sun well it doesn't because the
sun warps
this space-time canvas which is not a
canvas which is a concept turned into an
object which you deny at the end of your
presentation and you say that's what
gravity is
well between the two i'll go with the
angel anytime
i mean i think it's more rational at
least i can see the angel pushing the
earth i can understand that this
nonsense we no one can understand
or or you get the electromagnetic wave
you say okay what is an electromagnetic
wave that's light okay what is it and
what it is is a field a couple fields
perpendicular fields okay what's a field
well it's uh just a bunch of numbers
that are flowing
numbers flowing
what is this bitcoin i mean
[Laughter]
the numbers are flowing and they have
direction you know i mean what the hell
is this
this is not a rational explanation
because you don't have a physical object
so again i'd rather go with god and the
angels than with this nonsense on the
right
and then when you go to god and the
angels well there are problems there too
i mean among others you know why would
the angel have wings if he's got a
nothing to flap against
in space out there you know among others
you know
so uh and what's pushing him and so on
okay so so all i'm saying is you can
make any assumptions you want like i
pointed out some time back a couple
weeks ago i think uh you know you can
make an assumption that a unicorn made a
hole in the wall by ramming it with his
with his horn right
you can make that assumption
okay now
we just want to know what's inside your
brain we want to know what mechanism you
propose for the hole on the wall
and you say what was a unicorn okay
that's your
explanation if that's the one you
believe i can't take it away from your
brain anyways i mean that's when you
believe
the uh
i mean i can invent a horse that's got a
horn and call him a unicorn and say well
it was a unicorn that did that because i
i i have a horse that has a horn it's an
artificial horn that i built into his
head and he just rams things with it
okay so that's how you think the hole
was made another person might say it was
a rock or a drill or whatever so we have
different explanations
and we just need to know what's going on
through your head what explanation you
give it and from there everybody then
goes home and does his own religion
believes in whichever one he wants
but certainly you cannot
come to the to the um
conference and say
the whole was made by time
what do you mean was made by time yeah
time bent inside the wall and made the
hole i mean this is the kind of answers
you get from mathematical physics and of
course at the end of it they say first
time is not an object and then they say
well we don't understand it either and
we don't care because we do math we do
equations
okay final issue fellas finally
discovered ken wheeler kenny wheeler
poor fellow there
and so angry angry uh buddhist
and so he discovered uh
uh wheeler he thinks that wheeler has
something in common with me and so i got
to stop him right there no
kenny doesn't have absolutely nothing in
common with my theory at all okay what
does kenny do well he invents uh fancy
words he uses throws him around like if
you knew what he's talking about and
everybody says oh look at all those big
words he's using he must be intelligent
and so what does he push around he puts
his around ether
what is ether field dielectric whoa
energy
inertia
and then uh what counter space
well counter space is uh the amount of
space i need on the counter for my beer
that's that's about all i know about
counter space the only word that maybe
has anything to do with science because
all the other all these other words have
nothing to do with physics or science
but uh and that's the one he uses to do
his presentation so you know he can spin
all this stuff around and think he's
talking
uh sensibly when he's not he's gotta
define these words when you look at his
definitions they're even worse than the
words that he uses
okay but then he goes into matter that's
the only one that uh has something to do
with anything with with physics but he
defines it as what as ultra high energy
wet light okay we don't know what the
energy is he doesn't know what light is
so
we're back to nothing yeah i know kenny
uh he's uh
he's just on the internet to make money
he's not there to teach you anything
regarding science you're never gonna
understand anything about how this
universe works through kenny wheeler
okay peoria
apophissis
[Laughter]
okay with that i'll see you next time uh
it'll probably be next week got a little
birthday party on uh sunday so i'll see
you next wednesday we'll see you then
bye